do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for my first official breakdown for
the final season of Game of Thrones this
will be my first of many videos about
this episode but let's dive right into
it the first thing I want to say is I
believe there was a lot of foreshadowing
in this episode I did notice many things
that could indicate which direction the
final season is heading in but let's
start off with the opening scene they
were not kidding when they said this
would be very reminiscent a king Robert
Baratheon's arrival in the first episode
of season 1 not only did they play the
same exact music but we also saw another
little boy climbing something in order
to get a good view of everyone arriving
that little kid definitely reminded me
of bran when he was climbing the castle
back in season 1 now I will say that
some of the scenes did feel a little
rushed at times I know they only have 6
episodes to wrap up the rest of the
story but I think they should have given
a couple scenes a little bit more room
to breathe now this episode opened up
exactly like most of us thought most of
what we saw was basically through the
eyes of Arya Stark which is also very
similar to how we saw King Robert's
arrival in season 1 in that first
episode we saw Sandor Clegane come
through the gates with the bastard
Joffrey Baratheon but this time he came
with another bastard who is actually
Robert Baratheon Sun which is Gendry now
most of you who have been following my
channel for a long time should already
know how I feel about Aria and Gendry
I've been wanting these two characters
to get back together from any seasons
now this is something else that could
have also been set up in the first
season when we saw Robert and Ned
speaking together in the crypts of
winter foul
we were meant to rule together if your
sister had lived would have been bound
by blood well it's not too late
I have a son you have a daughter will
join our houses Robert wanted to join
their houses ever since he fell in love
with Lyanna Stark but as we all know
that never happened
Robert was hoping he could still join
their houses by having Sansa and Joffrey
get married but that never happened
either however this can still be done
through Aria and Gendry
they were definitely giving us some
teases of this possibility in the
episode now as we all know the
northerners are not very fond of
outsiders not only does John have
Targaryen Zant Lannister's showing up
but he also has Danny's foreign army
showing up as well it was clear that the
northerners were not very happy about
this but I did love what Danny did when
John made her aware of that as soon as
John told Danny the northerners do not
trust outsiders Danny thought this would
be a good time to introduce them to our
dragons that's where I won her fell
there is a new sheriff in town and she
is not to be taken lightly
samwell tarly 'he's family had to learn
that the hard way but I'll get into that
later now I want to talk about what
happens when John and Danny actually get
inside of the castle walls degree brain
and Sansa as you all know I have been
highly anticipating the reunion between
John Snow and brain stark I've been
waiting for this day ever since John
left Winterfell in the second episode of
the show I was very happy that John and
bran were able to reconnect before one
of them gets killed but of course bran
is a super weirdo
which John did notice right away I
thought it was funny when John looked at
Songza like who the hell is this guy
then it gets even more uncomfortable
when sons and Danny meet for the first
time I thought it was clear that Songza
was throwing some major shade at Danny
here Danny is trying to compliment songs
on how beautiful she is
but songs is just like yeah whatever
wonderful was yours your grace now if
you remember this is exactly what Ned
Stark said to Robert Baratheon when he
showed up so we can see this opening
scene as many different similarities to
the first episode of season 1 9 years I
have not seen you where the hell have
you been guarding the north for you your
grace
Winterfell is yours
now what happens next is definitely one
of the things I felt was rushed right
asan's and Danny are talking Brannon
erupts in them to tell Danny they don't
have enough time for all the hugs and
kisses the night king is coming and he
has your damn dragon bran was not
messing around when he said that to
Danny he was super aggressive but at the
same time they have to understand they
seriously cannot play any games the only
thing I didn't like about this is they
did not give Danny very much time to
react to the news of the night King
taking her dragon they did show her in
John's face very quick but then they cut
the scene I was hoping we can hear Danny
say something about this I wanted to
know what she had to say because she
will have to come to terms with the fact
that she might have to be the one to
kill this Ariane for the second time now
the next scene also shows something that
I think most of us expected here we get
our first council meeting in Winterfell
I think it's safe to say that Lyanna
Mormont is not happy that John bent the
knee my god did she lay in a Jon Snow's
ass in that scene she did not hold back
when letting him know exactly how she
felt as I've said before this was
expected we did know all the northerners
would be very upset at Jon but they're
soon gonna find out that he did make the
right choice as of right now not too
many characters I've seen the army of
the Dead they still don't understand
just how real and dangerous they are
once they do see the Dead face to face
they will be begging Daenerys to use her
dragons they will be thanking their old
gods Daenerys brought all the unsullied
and Dothraki soldiers it won't be long
before they realize just how badly they
need to narrow star garyun support now I
was hoping that we could get a reunion
between Jorah Mormont and Lyanna Mormont
somewhere during that scene but I'm
guessing they're saving that for later
maybe we can get that in the next
episode I really can't wait to see what
Liana has to say to Jorah for disgracing
their family name now during this scene
Sansa does mention something that I have
voiced my concern about as well how the
hell they gonna feed all these men the
north only has enough food to feed the
north like Sansa said she did not
account for thousands and thousands of
extra soldiers not to mention Danny does
have two big-ass dragons that need to be
fed as well now we just have to hope
they don't get so hungry they start to
eat the children again did anyone else
love Danny's response as much as I did I
was happy that she fired right back at
Sansa
when Sansa says what do dragons eat
anyway
Danny says whatever they want then she
looks right at song zone almost as if
that's right so Anza I can get nasty too
now let's move on to Sons and Tyrion
Lannister's reunion because I do think
we got some foreshadowing right at the
end of the scene I think most of us were
highly anticipating these two characters
meaning again just like Tyrion said they
haven't seen each other since Joffrey's
wedding it's funny because when Tyrion
mentions that Sansa does say something
else that I thought was very funny
he said the wedding was a miserable
affair then Santa said it had its
moments which we all know what she is
referring to when we saw that little rat
bastard drop dead what a spectacular
moment now during this scene they talk
about Cersei sending her soldiers to
help fight the army of the dead you can
see that sunzha does Hart tyrians
feelings during that scene she can't
believe that Tyrion would actually
believe Cersei sons already knows that
Cersei isn't about to send any men then
she insults Tyrians intelligence when
she said she used to think he was the
cleverest man alive now what happens
after Sansa walks away is where I
believe we get our foreshadowing did any
of you notice the way bran was looking
at Tyrion Lannister I think he is
already suspicious of Tyrians intentions
I think he's about to go check Tyrians
internet history don't be surprised if
brain starts to look into the weirwood
net to see what Tyrion and Cersei talked
about after their final scene together
ended remember when Tyrion noticed sir
she was holding her stomach and not
drinking any alcohol he did come to the
realization that Cersei had to be
pregnant right as Tyrion says that to
Cersei the scene cuts away we don't know
what else was said but the look on
branes face after Sansa walks away from
the conversation makes me think we could
get a reveal about Tyrion in a later
episode don't forget about one of my
recent videos either I don't know how
many of you saw it but not only do I
think Tyrion will betray Daenerys but I
also think Varys will betray Daenerys as
well I think we get some more the
foreshadowing for this later in the
episode when we see Davos talk in a
Tyrion and Varys alright folks so now I
want to come to the reunion
I have been anticipating the most and
that is the reunion between Jon Snow and
Arya Stark in the scene we can see that
Arya uses her faceless men skills to
sneak up on Jon what she does mention
how did you sneak up on me Jon actually
has no idea
how much training Aria has went through
nor does even want to know how many
people Aria has killed which is also
mentioned when he notices she still has
needle now one thing I did find
interesting is Aria did not show John
her Valyrian steel dagger John shows her
long claw and she even mentions that
it's Valyrian steel but she did not show
John that she has her own Valyrian steel
I wonder why that is
also Arya said that John sword was too
heavy which I also find interesting
because one thing we do know about
Valyrian steel is it's not as heavy as
it looks Valyrian steel is actually
lighter than most swords based on the
scene it does seem like Arya is becoming
her old self a little more we did see
her smile in the episode many many times
and she even wants to support sons as
much as she does John hopefully that is
a sign that Arya will not go totally to
the dark side now that she's back home
and around all of her family maybe it's
not too late for Arya to live some sort
of a normal life assuming she doesn't
die in one of the upcoming battles now
let's go down to King's Landing where
Cersei learns that the army of the Dead
are advancing south
Cersei does not give a damn in Qyburn
gives a look like this [ __ ] is crazy
then we get our first good look at Harry
strickland commander of the golden
company right down below and the cabin
is where your on is keeping your agree
joy I was happy to see that she is not
only alive but she does still have her
tongue as of right now now this scene
may have also had some foreshadowing
Yara tells you're on you are fighting
for the losing side
Euron says exactly what I thought he
would do he says well then I will sell
the iron fleet somewhere else now that
you're on and Cersei are having sex I
don't see that happening right away
Euron will do everything that he can to
either marry Cersei and become the king
or he will try to kill Cersei and become
the king but there is also a third
option whenever Euron does realize he's
fighting for the losing side I can
easily see him abandoning King's Landing
either way Cersei cannot trust euron
greyjoy that was foreshadowed a couple
times already to my Armada and the
Narrow Sea
Yulin Greyjoy some others there's hungry
Joe is loyal to me for now the scene
that I like the reference is when
Tycho's from the iron bank told Cersei
what would happen you might have your
own Greyjoy at your side right
but you won't have him at your side
forever then we get one of the scenes
from the trailer where Cersei meets what
your own and Harry Strickland
unfortunately we will not see the
elephant's fighting in any other battles
now after Harry Strickland leaves
Euron does exactly what I said he would
do he would talk Cersei into having sex
with him now in my opinion I did think
that Cersei would play a little harder
to get I was expecting him to have to
get a little more threatening before
Cersei would Bend but nonetheless she
did realize now that Jaime is gone she
cannot afford to lose your on Graduate -
he has already shown his value many
times now I do have to admit the scene
we got what bran was very unexpected I
did think we would see him but I did not
think it would be like this Cersei
thinks it would be poetic justice if
Tyrion got killed what the same crossbow
that he used to kill their father well
Tyrion and Jaime but you know what I
mean now of course they did make it look
like bran was considering the offer but
I do not believe Bronn will try to kill
either one of them I know he has a cell
sword but come on Jaime and Tyrion are
his homies I just really don't see
either one of them getting killed that
way alright now the next scene was
something I did predict in one of my
videos I said the easiest way for Theon
and get Yara back without having to go
up against you're on at full force is to
catch him slipping in the middle of the
night almost like a Navy SEALs mission
the only thing that didn't happen is I
was hoping Theon would set your on ships
on fire before he left that would have
really crippled Cersei and Euron's force
now although I did think of what
happened it did seem a little rushed and
a little too easy for Theon he was able
to get yara free and have her looking
all cleaned up within a matter of
minutes
Theon rescues her in the first scene
then it immediately cuts to them far out
at sea I think they should have made
these two different scenes separate that
way it felt like some time had went by
but that's just me now what's
interesting is Theon is now heading to
Winterfell to fight in the battle
against the night king so we might not
see Theon and Euron face off until the
second half of the season unless we see
Yara try to kill him since her and Theon
seem to be going their separate ways you
have to wonder what they will do a Yara
from here on out I hope she doesn't just
disappear from the story until the end
of the season now Yara did say something
that could be foreshadowing a future
event when we hear her talk about the
iron
she says Daenerys will need somewhere to
retreat to if they can't hold the north
somewhere the knight King cannot reach
with his entire army like an island that
could be foreshadowing John Danny and
everyone else having to flee from
Winterfell back to the sea now if you
remember and one of the most recent
trailers we could see that Danny had her
back turned to John the fireplace in the
room looks like the one on Dragonstone
so maybe John and Danny do have to leave
the north even if they did beat the
night King at Winterfell the castle
still may take too much damage for
anyone to live there so we may see them
back on Dragonstone either way it does
look like fiona is starting to get some
of his confidence back hopefully that
means he can be very useful during the
battle for Winterfell because as we all
know they do need every swing and dick
in the field
although Theo no longer has a dick all
right so now let's get back to some more
the foreshadowing from the episode we go
back to Winterfell where we see the
Karstarks have arrived but I want to
talk about the conversation Davos has
with tyrion and varys
in that scene Davos is talking to Tyrion
and Varys about loyalty now try to
remember if you saw my video about
Tyrion and Varys betray and Dany then
you would know it was their loyalty that
has been put into question many times
now Davos may have been talking about
the northern man named Daenerys but you
have to read between the lines here it's
no coincidence that Tyrion and Varys are
together once again during a
conversation about loyalty when they do
notice John and Danny together they
start to talk about how they won't be as
needed or wanted around like they used
to you can get a sense that Tyrion and
Varys may start to feel like they are
underappreciated
remember this conversation started off
with them talking about loyalty and the
conversation ends what Varys saying
nothing lasts forever if you ever think
I'm fading the people you won't conspire
behind my back you look me in the eye as
you have done today and you'll tell me
how I'm failing me I swear it my queen
I think that maybe once again
foreshadowing a betrayal coming from
tyrion and varys now let's move on to
John and Danny scene this leads to one
of the moments I have been waiting for
for quite some time John Snow
also known as Aegon Targaryen ride
Danny's dragon Ragle which is named
after his father Rhaegar Targaryen I
thought this would actually happen after
John finds out that he is a Targaryen I
thought it would be that revelation that
gave Danny and John the confidence that
John could even ride a dragon by himself
but they had him ride the dragon before
he found out now was it just me or did
Ragle look like he was extra green in
the episode I think he really stood out
now we already know John had a
connection with the Dragons or at least
you're gone but I was surprised at how
easy it was for him to mount ragel I was
expecting a little more resistance ragel
did not even hesitate to let John on his
back I thought that was interesting I
guess you could say John was born to
ride that dragon now that should make
the battle for Winterfell even more
interesting the night king may have a
dragon but Danny still has two dragons
and she now has two riders this can make
their dragon strike so much more
accurate now that someone is directing
the other one there will be a dance with
dragons right over Winterfell which
should make for one hell of a sight to
see
now when John and Danny do get off the
Dragons Danny said something to John
that immediately reminded me of Ygritte
for some reason when Danny looks at the
waterfall she says we could stay here
for a thousand years which basically
means that Danny wants to stay there
what Jon forever now if you remember
right as Ygritte is about to die she
says we should have stayed in that cave
hopefully that doesn't mean Dany dies
right in John's arms and before she dies
she says we should have stayed at the
waterfall oh yeah one other thing who
else thought it was really funny when
drug on was staring at John when he was
kissing Daenerys I couldn't help but
laugh at the look one drug on his face
that [ __ ] was funny now in the next
scene we get a double dose of reunions
or EEOC's ginjury and she talks to
Sandor Clegane for the first time ever
since she left him for dead which the
Hound did mention right away I was
hoping that Aria and Sandor would have
some more time to talk but this did open
up more time for Arya and Kendra to talk
like I said at the beginning of the
video they were showing some of the cam
Street between Aria and ginjury right
away they complemented each other's
looks an aria smiled at him several
times then she did that little flirting
turn around and smiled as she left a
room you ladies know exactly what I'm
talking about now I am interested in
getting a good look at the weapon Gendry
makes fer Aria I'm assuming it's the one
we see her use in the trailer when she's
fighting on the battlements now I want
to get to the scene everyone was asking
about during the off season this is when
we see Daenerys and Jorah go to visit
Saemaul Tarly
obviously Danny thanks Sam for saving
jours life but Sam says something that I
want everyone to remember Sam tells
Danny that he had taken some of the
books from the Citadel this is
foreshadowing those books coming into
play later you could see that Sam was
already looking through them when Danny
showed up but he will eventually find
something in those books that is a big
revelation
I'm guessing it's gonna have something
to do with the night king and that may
lead to Sam telling Brian where to look
inside of the weirwood net for answers
so just keep that in the back of your
mind those books were referenced because
they will come up again now the moment
everyone has been waiting for is when
Sam finds out that Danny killed his
brother and father now we already know
that Sam and Randall did not have a very
good relationship but Sam did love his
brother he was obviously very hurt by
that news now do I think Sam will betray
John or Daenerys because of that
absolutely not but it could make things
very uncomfortable for the next few
episodes regardless of how upset Sam is
he still does need to protect little Sam
and Gilly and he knows that Daenerys and
John give him the best chance of
defeating the night king I don't see Sam
leaving anytime soon he has to be there
to help bran find the answers now trust
me it does suck that sames brother chose
to stand by his father but he did make
that decision on his own you can clearly
see that Sam is heartbroken when he
leaves the room but that does lead to
another very interesting scene when Sam
goes outside he sees bran Stark who is
sitting out there waiting for an old
friend now you might think he was
talking about Sam but we later find out
who he might have actually been talking
about which is Jaime Lannister who shows
up in the final scene now I was really
hoping that brand told John about
Rhaegar and Lyanna or at the very least
I wanted brand to be in the room when it
happened
I also did not like that bran said he is
not John's brother I mean sure if you
want to
technical it's true John and brain are
not brothers but I mean come on they
grew up like brothers
and as brothers I was also surprised
that Danny did not tell John she
executed Sam's brother and father she
obviously already told jorah mormont and
I wonder why she didn't tell John I can
only assume that she knew Sam and John
were friends because Sam was the one
that sent the letter to Dragonstone
about all the dragonglass
unless John never said his last name but
I did think it was odd that John did not
know you would think someone would have
told him what happened during the battle
even tyrion lanister could have said
something but anyway let's get to the
scene that everyone was waiting for
since the very first book was released
now I did think this would happen later
but John finds out about Liana and
Rhaegar in the opening episode Sam tells
John you're not just a king in the north
you're the king of the Seven Kingdoms
this is about to make [ __ ] very
interesting between John and Daenerys
not only are they related but John now
has the better claim to the Iron Throne
what's Daenerys gonna have to say about
that how will that affect their
relationship
what about Sansa in the rest of the
northerners I mean that is a lot for
everyone to take in we already know Lord
Glover did not show up in Winterfell but
what about the other lords that are
there could we see any of their
supporters begin to abandon them for
some reason I think this will have a
bigger effect on Sansa then it will Arya
I could see signs of becoming even more
distant from John then again I also
think when the night King shows up none
of that's gonna matter that's when they
will truly learn that they need everyone
no matter which family they come from
but I do really want to move on to the
next scene because I think it's easily
one of the most fascinating scenes from
the episode here we can see mr. Don
Darian and mr. Giantsbane this scene was
shown in the trailer and I did say I
thought it would be the last hearth or
the karhold because it did look like a
different castle than the ones we
usually see you can tell that something
happened here but we do not see any dead
bodies laying around that most likely
means the night King has already turned
them all into whites now when they go
inside they do run into lower commander
ed and the rest of the Nights Watch that
is left this is when we get a very
interesting reveal little Ned umber is
dead
the night King had his body mounted to
the wall and surrounding his body is the
same symbol we have seen time and time
again
what happens to the symbol is what I
really want to talk about when that
number comes back as a white beric
Dondarrion stabs him with the burning
sword that causes the entire symbol to
catch on fire now take a look at the
imagery remember where we have seen that
symbol before we saw this at the
three-eyed Ravens cave which is also the
same location the knight King was
created as I've said before the knight
King has to be getting his magical
abilities from the same place as the
children of the forest since they did
create him after all he was tied around
a weirwood tree when they shoved the
dragon glass into his chest when he
became the knight King he had very
similar powers as the children of the
forest not only can he enter the mind of
animals and other people but he can also
go inside of the weirwood net the knight
king could even affect things inside of
the weirwood net because he did that
when he grabbed Bereans arm this is how
the knight king is getting all of his
powers the knight King leaves that
symbol because it represents the same
thing that gives him those magical
abilities so maybe in order to defeat
the knight king you might have to
actually burn down his main power source
which might be the weirwood trees they
might have to burn just like we see
symbolized at the end of the scene this
is something that Melisandre talks about
time and time again in the books
Melisandre is always having the weirwood
trees burned down and she even says the
Jon burned these where woods and except
Winterfell as a gift of the Lord of
Light since the night King seems to be
getting his powers from the where woods
they might have to burn them down the
Hart Sharia Winterfell may also have to
be burned it's also interesting that the
where woods are also called Hart trees
because as we see on Melisandre spanners
there is a burning heart now you could
also say the symbol looks a lot like the
Targaryen sigil either way I think the
symbols have a deeper meaning because
the knight king has been leaving them
behind ever since the very first episode
of the show I will be releasing another
video about this soon
but first I will have to take some more
time to do a little research now the
very last scene had me just as excited
as this one this was one hell of a
cliffhanger very similar to how the
first episode in season 1 ended bran
actually set his ass out there all night
all jacked up on adderall just waiting
for his old friend to show up I can't
even explain the feeling that I had when
brain and Jaime locked eyes in the
courtyard this is easily one of the most
highly-anticipated reunions and not just
gameofthrones history but also
television history in my opinion now we
know they don't kill Jamie just based on
the trailer alone
we already saw Jamie fighting in the
battle for Winterfell but I do wonder
when Jamie's little secret gets exposed
in front of everyone since things are
moving so fast I have to assume this
will come out almost right away like I
have said in other videos about this
confrontation ultimately I think brain
stark will forgive Jamie actually brain
is so out of touch who really knows what
the hell he says but I have always said
that brain most likely sees him becoming
the new three-eyed raven as part of his
destiny almost like something that had
to happen now that doesn't mean every
other stork will see things like that
but I think brain will either way it
still doesn't take away from the scene
even though I do think bran forgives him
I still had goosebumps when their eyes
met I was on the edge of my seat just
waiting to see what happened next but
HBO cut it off just at the right moment
to have us all wanting more I absolutely
love that as the final scene I thought
it was a perfect way to end the episode
that already had so many similarities to
season ones first episode I'm definitely
anxious to see how things play out
between Jamie and bran and John and
Danny now that Jon knows who he is and
of course I want to know where the night
king strikes next anyways I want to
thank all of you for stopping by to
watch the video like I said this will be
the first of many videos I make about
the opening episode I've only seen the
episode once so I still need to take a
second and third look there are still so
much to digest hopefully you did
subscribe to my channel by now because I
will be releasing a shitload of videos
during the six weeks I would love to see
you all come back for the next one have
a great day I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
Oh